cómo
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 hay
expectativa en washington en donde
avanza el segundo juicio político contra
el expresidente donald trump en un
momento el pleno del senado avaló la
solicitud de los fiscales demócratas de
llamar a testificar a algunos
legisladores republicanos una decisión
que retrasaría si la votación final de
este juicio hace unos minutos anunciaron
que finalmente continuarán con el juicio
sin necesidad de convocar a algunos
testigos tenemos los detalles en minutos
juramento como nuevo primer ministro de
italia el economista mario draghi ex
presidente del banco central europeo y
también una ficha clave de italia en la
unión europea con formará una coalición
de gobierno fortalecida que intentará
sacar a italia del estancamiento
político y de la crisis sanitaria y
económica en la que está inmersa
en perú oscar ugarte juró como nuevo
ministro de salud de ese país esto
después de la renuncia de pilar mazzetti
quien me por presión del congreso se vio
obligada a abandonar este cargo debido a
la polémica al darse a conocer que el
expresidente martín vizcarra fue
vacunado contra el hobbit 19 en octubre
pasado
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos hasta
ahora la atención está concentrada en la
ciudad de washington en donde minutos
minutos se van desarrollando allí los
hechos como les decíamos avanza el
juicio político el segundo contra el ex
presidente de donald trump que dados los
últimos acontecimientos podría
prolongarse más allá del día de hoy para
esta jornada estaba estipulado que
podría tener lugar esa votación final
sobre sí condenarían o absorberían a
trump del cargo de incitación a la
violencia por la insurrección del pasado
6 de enero que llevó a la toma del
capitolio previamente a lo largo de la
mañana los fiscales demócratas
solicitaron llamar a testigos
legisladores republicanos cambiando
hacia el panorama de la situación fue
votada esta iniciativa fue aprobada pero
hace unos minutos ya anunciaron desde
allí desde el pleno del senado que van a
continuar con este juicio contra trump
sin convocar a testigos sobre este tema
se pronunció jamie rasquín uno de los
fiscales demócratas en este juicio
político
anoche la congresista james butler del
estado de washington dio una declaración
confirmando que en medio de la
insurrección cuando el líder de la
minoría kevin mccarthy
llamó al presidente rogando por ayuda
el presidente de trump respondió y cito
justice que por muy bueno que bien creo
que estas personas están más enojadas
por la elección que tú dices
no hace falta decir que esta es una
pieza crítica de nueva evidencia que
confirma los cargos contra ustedes así
como la voluntad del presidente y su
negligencia en el deber como comandante
en jefe su estado mental y su incitación
a la insurrección el 6 de enero
vamos a conectar con cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de washington para conocer más detalles
cristóbal buenas tardes allí en la
capital de eeuu y en que varía entonces
esta reciente decisión de el senado que
acordaron ya entre las dos bancadas
seguir con el juicio no incorporar más
testigos
claro varía entonces que ya en este
momento están haciendo los comentarios
finales entonces los fiscales demócratas
tendrán dos horas y la defensa de donald
trump tendrá también dos horas para sus
últimos comentarios sobre el juicio para
que entonces se pase a votación y hoy
mismo entonces podría conocerse si
donald trump es hallado culpable o es
absuelto de los crímenes de insurrección
tras incitar a la violencia el pasado 6
de enero nadie se esperaba que los
fiscales demócratas james rating
esta mañana citar a testigos de hecho en
llamada periodistas los senadores
demócratas habían dicho que ya había un
preacuerdo entre las partes para que se
se hicieran los comentarios finales y se
votará alrededor de las 2 de la tarde
sin embargo el rating tras conocerse
este testimonio de herrera butler pues
dice que no que quiere llamar a testigos
y los republicanos entonces lo que
empiezan a decir es que se abre una caja
de pandora porque incluso ted cruise el
senador republicano dijo que se llamaban
pues los republicanos iban entonces a
llamar a nancy pelosi y se iba a alargar
muchísimo más
este juicio político algo que analistas
dicen no le conviene al presidente yo
bailé teniendo en cuenta la cantidad de
proyectos que tiene y de gente que tiene
que ser aprobada en el senado
precisamente para su gabinete así
entonces que esperan unas cuatro horas
máximo de argumentos finales y después
la votación final
cristóbal entonces volvemos a la página
original para el día de hoy en la agenda
que era la votación para absolver o para
condenar a donald trump ya teniendo ese
escenario entonces otra vez claro cómo
están las cargas para esa votación
claro se espera que sean no más de 57
senadores que voten en contra de donald
trump que quieran acusarlo insurrección
de hecho en declaraciones a la prensa el
senador ted cruz que se le fue
preguntado precisamente eso cuál es la
expectativa que tienen sobre la votación
y dice que entre 53 y 57 senadores
terminarían votando en contra de donald
trump es decir entre 3 y 7 senadores
republicanos cambiarían de bando de su
línea republicana para apoyar el juicio
político contra donald trump y pues
estar del bando de los demócratas pero
recordemos bien que se necesitan el 67
de los 100 votos que están disponibles
en el senado para que uno sea hallado
culpable es decir dos tercios dos
tercios del senado algo muy improbable
así que pues lo más probable es que si
la votación se llevó a cabo hoy que el
área se pronostica que se conozca el
resultado de las 66 y media
la noche donald trump se ha absuelto de
su segundo un juicio político como
crisis 17 votos republicanos
necesitarían entonces los demócratas
para condenar a trompas y sería el
escenario gracias cristóbal por esta
actualización desde la ciudad de
washington y seguimos muy atentos a todo
lo que ocurre allí en cualquier momento
regresaremos con usted vamos a avanzar
con otros temas de la agenda juramento
como nuevo primer ministro de italia el
economista mario draghi también ex
presidente del banco central europeo y
una de las fichas clave de italia en la
unión europea el conformar a una
coalición de gobierno fortalecida que
intentará sacar a italia del
estancamiento político y también de la
crisis sanitaria del joven 19 y la
crisis económica en la que está inmersa
andrea maya nos cuenta más en su informe
es el final de semanas de incertidumbre
mario draghi fue designado primer
ministro luego de la reunión con el
presidente sergio mataré la foto efe bra
yo el profesor mario draghi aceptó la
tarea de formar un nuevo gobierno y
presentó las propuestas al presidente
relativas al nombramiento de ministros
ministro el economista de 73 años
liderará un nuevo gobierno de unidad
nacional para reemplazar la coalición de
giuseppe conté que colapsó el mes pasado
reúne a tecnócratas y una variedad de
partidos políticos rivales desde los
liberales históricos hasta el movimiento
antisistema y la extrema derecha
luigi dimaggio líder del movimiento
cinco estrellas seguirá siendo ministro
de relaciones exteriores y giancarlo
giorgetti una figura destacada del
partido nacionalista liga se convertirá
en ministro de desarrollo económico sin
embargo algunos puestos claves fueron
para tecnócratas no afiliados entre
ellos daniel franco ex vicegobernador
del banco de italia quien encabezará el
ministerio de economía las figuras del
partido están de acuerdo
del lado sus diferencias al menos por
este momento mientras esperan decidir
cómo gastar a italia más de doscientos
mil millones de euros en fondos de
recuperación de la unión europea el país
se encuentra en su peor crisis económica
desde la segunda guerra mundial y sigue
luchando contra la pandemia de
coronavirus que ya se ha cobrado la vida
de más de 93 mil personas y en perú hay
nuevo ministro de salud francisco
zacarías nos cuenta más de delima
el presidente francisco sagasti
juramento a óscar ugarte como un nuevo
ministro de salud a él le tocará
desempeñar el cargo en el momento más
difícil de la pandemia del coi 19 que
vive este país con altos índices de
contagios y decesos
oscar ugarte además de dirigir la
vacunación tendrá que solucionar los
reclamos de los médicos que exigen
mejoras salariales y laborales
ugarte se integra al gobierno de
francisco sagasti tras la renuncia de
pilar mazzetti quien dimitió tras el
escándalo que relaciona al ex presidente
de martín vizcarra con las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 destino farc luego
que un medio local denunciara que martín
vizcarra y su esposa habrían sido
inoculados en octubre pasado esto
disgustó a varios congresistas quienes
responsabilizan a masetti y promovieron
una moción de la institución desde el
parlamento contra ella masetti se sintió
acorralada por el legislativo y dimitió
francisco sagasti decidió entonces
llamar a un conocido en gestión pública
para atender la pandemia así las cosas
esta noche oscar ugarte recibirá 700.000
dosis de la vacuna china y sino farc
para continuar la primera fase
nación de los peruanos esto en las
noticias buenas tardes
[Música]